okay so the the media and politicians
tell us there's a crisis an epidemic an
outbreak a catastrophe Emery these are
these are actual headlines these are
actual words and it's it's gripping our
our country and worse yet our children
think of the children they are caught in
the middle of this thing and and the
disaster is is so very disastrous that
the White House is now leaping into
action president Trump has announced
that his administration will move for a
ban on flavored cigarettes
so yes vaping vaping is the crisis
vaping is what threatens to bring down
the very structures of human
civilization it will bring about
Armageddon if we do not act immediately
we'll talk about this this vaping ban
which i think is not only stupid
completely without basis unjustified but
also politically catastrophic for the
president in many ways we're going to
talk about that in a second but first no
one you know really has time to go to
the post office you're busy you got a
lot of stuff to do you don't to deal
with the traffic in the parking and
bring me all your packages and it can be
a real hassle that's why you need stamps
calm one of the most popular time-saving
tools for small businesses stamps calm
eliminates trips to the post office and
it saves you money as well as time with
all of the discounts that you can't even
get at the post office stamps calm
brings all the amazing services of the
post office right to your computer right
to your house whether you're a small
business sending out invoices or your
big warehouse shipping out orders
whatever the case is whatever your needs
are stamps calm is there to handle it
with ease simply use your computer print
official US pass postage 24/7 for any
letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it and then
once you're ready just drop it in your
in your mailbox and you're good to go
now right now my listeners get a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
without any long-term commitment all you
have to do is go to stamps.com click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in Walsh that's stamps
comm enter Walsh and start to save time
and money so they
is the crisis that we're dealing with
this week Trump at the White House
yesterday talked to reporters about his
plan to ban most almost all flavors of
e-cigarettes and well look I'll play
this for you and you tell me if his
explanation makes any sense at all
listen to this but we can't allow people
to get sick and we can't have our youth
be so affected and I'm hearing it and
that's how the first lady got involved
she's got a son together that is a
beautiful young man and she feels very
very strongly about it she's seen it
we're both reading it a lot of people
are reading it but people are dying with
vaping so we're looking at it very
closely and you know if nothing else
this is a conference that's going to let
people know about it because people are
gonna watch what we're saying and
parents are going to be a lot tougher
with respect to their children a lot of
people think vaping is wonderful it's
great it's really not wonderful that's
one thing I think we can say definitely
commissioner it's not a wonderful thing
it's got big problems we have to find
out the extent of the problem it's so
new it's so new but we're gonna find out
and I hope that parents that you know
they have children and the children are
a certain age I hope they're going to be
able to make wise decisions maybe based
on what we're saying today but the
Commissioner and Alexei czar they're
going to be coming back over the next
pretty short period of time a couple of
weeks with some very strong
recommendations well okay then
uh yeah let's ban it because Melania
doesn't like it that's basically his
reason yeah oh my wife doesn't like it
so we're gonna get rid of it great idea
yeah because Melania is son not his son
in Melania so people are harping on that
where he said milania's son and I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna heart but it is a
weird it is a weird way of describing
your own child I can I can't imagine
referring to my son as you know my
wife's son just very strange but anyway
he says milania's son is a beautiful
young man and that's why we should ban
vape ink all right great
makes total sense now leaving aside the
not insignificant question of whether
the president has the constitutional
authority to unilaterally ban a consumer
product and by the way the answer is no
he does not
not even close I think the question we
have to ask ourselves is is is all of
this apocalyptic fervor justified is
there really anything that might
reasonably be described as a vaping
epidemic as we're being told and this
isn't just again the president this is
this is the media these are many other
politicians are talking about the vaping
epidemic is there one hour are people
dropping dead left and right in a street
because of vaping the answer of course
is no not even close
there have been six deaths in America
possibly linked to vaping now I say
possibly now the media reports it as yet
these are vaping deaths but I don't
think we're at a point where we can 100%
make that connection so these are deaths
that are possibly in some way to some
degree linked to vaping six that's out
of the more than 11 million people who
report using e-cigarettes if you're
keeping track at home six out of 11
million that is a fatality rate of point
zero zero zero five percent okay so that
is a half of a half of a half of a half
of a percent have died by comparison if
you look at other substances that also
have a death toll of their own
eighty-eight thousand people a year die
from alcohol-related causes 128 thousand
people every year die from prescription
pill related things the death the death
toll in both of those cases does
represent of course a a small percentage
as well but it's probably a higher
percentage than point zero zero zero
zero five percent so no matter how you
look at it the numbers do
come anywhere close to justifying words
like outbreak and catastrophe and crisis
and epidemic and they certainly don't
justify an unconstitutional action from
the president not that anything ever
could justify an unconstitutional action
from the president but certainly if
anything ever could which it couldn't
this wouldn't be it but the panic is is
so hopefully by now with all of those
facts in mind if you hadn't done any
research on this
hopefully just just being told that
point zero zero zero zero five percent
of people who vaped have died allegedly
maybe possibly because of it that should
be enough to tell you this is not a
crisis this is not an epidemic you know
if that level of fatality rate is enough
to ban something then we need to ban
literally everything because I think any
object or substance you can think of
probably kills at least point zero zero
zero five percent of the people who come
in contact with it or use it just any
carrots I'm willing to bet that more
than point zero zero zero five percent
of all people who've eaten carrots have
died from choking I'm I don't know I'm
just making that up but I bet you that
percentage is at least around that
number probably more than that so that
should be enough but the panic that
around vaping is even more absurd and
counterproductive than it first appears
because keep in mind that the majority
of people who've gotten sick or died
from vaping we're using unlicensed black
market products what they're banning
here are flavored the fruity flavored
cigarette stuff that you can go and buy
at the gas station or the grocery store
that's not what's killing people the
very very small percentage of people
who've gotten have been killed or gotten
sick most of them over eighty percent of
them by the number that I saw we're
using unlicensed black market products
that they got off the street so by now
now here's the point I just put
this together by outlying most East
cigarettes what we're doing is we're
it's not just that we're missing the
point and we are outlawing something
that hasn't even been caused probably
we're driving more people towards
precisely the kind of vaping that's
causing the problem in the first place
so if the point if you if you ban it and
you say you can't get it then the only
way people can get it is on the black
market which means now you can have more
people going to the black market than
we're before this is a solution to a
fake problem that will inevitably cause
the fake problem to become a real
problem in other words this is exactly
the kind of solution our government
specializes in now I say I just want to
stipulate here I say all this not
because I like to vape I don't think
I've never vaped it's not my thing
I find it kind of weird to be honest and
I think it looks weird and it looks
stupid in my opinion and and so I it's
just it's not what I would do if if I
want to smoke something I'm gonna have a
cigar on occasion which by the way is
way more unhealthy than vaping and I and
I fully acknowledge that smoking a cigar
is like smoking 40 cigarettes at once or
something it's it's just insane amount
of tobacco that you are inhaling when
you smoke a cigar but I do on occasion
that's my choice as an adult the fact
that I find vaping to be kind of weird
and not my thing
that is not in itself enough to justify
sweeping prohibitions this fact
apparently is news to the president who
thinks that the fact that his wife
doesn't like something means that we
should get rid of it now really my my
toxin of choice aside from cigars is
alcohol I drink in moderation but I do
like to drink beer bourbon whatever and
it would probably be healthier if I
didn't drink at all there have been
studies that show that whatever having
one glass of wine a day is good for you
or I don't know
was one glass line a wino a week or
something so there have been different
studies but but probably overall it
would be healthier if I didn't drink at
all probably maybe even I would live
longer a little bit longer like if I'm
gonna die at 83 if I'm if I am set to
die at 83 or 85 let's say and if I
didn't drink maybe if I I'm set to die
at 85 if I don't drink if I do drink
I'll die at 83 or so I don't know you
know it could be something like that
they say it shaves a couple of years off
your life but that's my decision and
that's my concern and the way I look at
it is it's something that I enjoy doing
and you know it's it makes life a little
bit more enjoyable just a small little
joy and so if this small little joy
shaves off a couple years at the end of
life then I'm willing to make that that
that bargain I mean probably if I didn't
drink at all and I didn't eat any red
meat and you know I was I I didn't he'd
have never had any junk food and I I
just got rid of all those pleasures in
life I could tack on I don't know five
years for me that trade just really
isn't worth it what's the point but
that's my concern that's my business
that's my decision is the point here you
don't have to agree with it doesn't
matter you know it doesn't I don't care
what your opinion is I don't care what
the opinion of the president is I
shouldn't have to care you can give me
your opinion you shouldn't be able to
impose it you shouldn't be able to say I
don't personally like that thing so
therefore let's get rid of it that's not
how it's supposed to work in a free
country but if we are gonna start
banning unhealthy substances the thing
is we have a lot of banning to do before
we get to the comparatively mild and
safe cigarettes and we shouldn't start
with alcohol either the government tried
that once you may recall and it didn't
turn out very well the leading cause of
death in America is obesity so with
obesity okay now you're talking about
something that maybe you could actually
call in a public health emergency
people are very fat in this country and
they're only getting fatter yet soda and
fast food which are two staple staples
of trumps diet by the way remain not
only legal but are often marketed
specifically to kids so how are you
gonna say was we got to get rid of the
fruity cigarettes because kids are using
them meanwhile you got happy meals that
what me what do you think's gonna kill
you say if you eat fast food every day
or if you vape every day who's gonna die
sooner let's do a race have one person
eat fast food every day have another
person vape every day who lives longer
what do you think or who gets to their
gravestone sooner let's put it that way
probably the person with the fast food
yet that's still legal because if I feel
like having an unhealthy lunch I'm gonna
have an unhealthy lunch I don't care
what your opinion is I'm just gonna do
it because I want to because I'm an
adult and this is America this is one of
the things that's supposed to set us
apart from other countries so it just
it's this is completely insane it really
is an insane move by the president
especially and I think politically
disastrous now banning vaping who is
that going to appeal to politically
we've talked about we've talked about
whether or not this makes a logical
sense and it doesn't so this this law
cannot be logically immoral or morally
or legally justified on constitutional
basis but then let's ask a a more
peripheral question which is it does
does it at least make political sense
and the crazy thing is it doesn't even
make political sense so it's a bad
stupid policy that won't even help
President Trump
politically who's it going to appeal to
this is going to appeal to a certain
collection of basically Fox News viewing
baby boomers that see kids vaping and
they say oh this stupid kids with a
vaping get rid of that it's gonna it's
going to appeal to that particular set
of people those are gonna be the only
ones who are in favor of this
the thing is though that is a relative
people in that that group but it's a
comparatively small group and the other
thing is President Trump already has
those people Fox News viewing baby
boomers are 100% behind Donald Trump
they're gonna be there in droves already
so you have to look at who are you
potentially alienating with something
like this well primarily Millennials
younger voters and those are exactly the
voters that Trump does not automatically
have those are the ones he needs to win
he won in 2016 and I keep saying this I
know that there are Trump fans who want
to believe that Trump won by a landslide
and it was just a huge outpouring of
support and it wasn't he won with three
million fewer votes overall and he won
because of a few hundred thousand votes
in a few states and he got and and and
and he was helped by the fact that the
Democrats put up for the fort fort for
in the general election easily the most
unlikable major party candidate ever in
American history and even with that
advantage he won by a few hundred
thousand votes in a few states
it's a razor thin margin and considering
his problem have the advantage of
running against Hillary Clinton that's
not gonna happen as much as we would
like it if it did so he's gonna probably
need more votes than he had last time
he's not gonna be able to skate by with
what he had last he didn't even more
than that he needs to build his
coalition which means doing more than
just appealing to the Fox News viewing
baby boomers and by the way no
disrespect of it to those of you if
you're in that okay no disrespect to you
I'm just saying you're in you know
you're in Trump's corner great he needs
more than than you and he needs
Millennials and and this at least some I
know he's at least some he needs he
needs a certain coalition of younger
people and this is the kind of thing
that just isn't gonna help and I'm
talking about just people who vape and
won't like like that I don't vape I'm
extremely annoyed by this because I
really hate it when the government does
this when the government starts banning
this nanny state BS I hate I hate it on
principle
they started banning large sodas in New
York I hated that - I don't live in New
York and I don't drink soda I still hate
it I don't like being treated like a
child by the government and I don't like
it when government officials tried to
impose their own personal preferences on
the public alright let's see I thought
this was this was interesting back just
really quickly I wanted I wanted to
mention this back in 2009 archaeologists
unearthed two skeletons in Italy dating
back to maybe the 4th century AD and
these were skeletons that were buried
holding hands apparently and and when
they were dug up they were they were
still holding hands they become the
skeletons became known as the lovers of
Modena and and anyways we knew about
that and so you see the skeletons
holding hands and you start coming up
with all these narratives of some some
romantic epic that must have led to
these two lovers supposedly dying
together holding hands well scientists
have just completed some studies on
these skeletons and they've discovered
based they listen based on the proteins
in their tooth enamel which is amazing
by the way that they can do this sixteen
hundred years later they can analyze
protein in tooth and an enamel and come
to the conclusion that these were both
males both guys which said no microphone
which means that they they weren't
lovers because back in the fourth
century you know they weren't going to
bury two gay men together romantically
with their hands clasp that just that
wasn't that wasn't that it wasn't the
culture back then so they were probably
family members or maybe soldiers who
died in battle or something like that in
any case this is this what just jumped
out at me about it isn't this
interesting that they could determine
the sex of people who live sixteen
hundred years ago sixteen centuries and
they can tell the sex of these people
hmm-hmm it's almost like yeah I don't
know but it's almost like sex is a
physical trade that can be
scientifically determined by observation
it almost seems that way doesn't it if
we can go back to people who died over
millennia millennium ago and find out
their sex it it would seem that sex is a
therefore a biological trait I don't
know but that's just that's that's how
it would seem to me and in all
seriousness we are I we're gonna get to
the point with this woke gender identity
stuff on the Left we're to get to the
point where basically archaeologists and
anthropologists and scientists who deal
with this stuff won't be able to do
their jobs anymore because eventually
the left's gonna notice that hell will
hold a wait a second if we go back we
start saying you know digging up
skeletons and saying what sexy people
that completely undermines our entire
gender identity thing and so eventually
they're gonna circle back and say no no
you guys can't do that anymore you're
not allowed to all you could do is dig
up a skeleton and say we know nothing
about this is just this could be
anything might not even be a human who
knows all right you want to see the
saddest thing of all time Hillary
Clinton participated in a art exhibit in
Venice that involved her sitting behind
a fake resolute desk for an hour and
reading her emails I'm not kidding this
actually happened take a look at this
here's a here's a photograph of it there
she is
yes she this was an art exhibit she went
to Venice and she sat behind a fake
presidential desk and read her emails
wow I have nothing else to say about
that other than that really is the most
pitiful sight I may be ever seen I mean
it almost makes me want to cry and I
don't even
it's just it's so sad and it just
embarrassing you just you you wanna you
cringe into a into a small tiny little
ball well this okay so that either that
was the most pitiful and saddest thing
I've ever seen or maybe it's actually
this I'm not sure there was yesterday on
9/11 there was a queue Anan rally in DC
and we'll summer of The Daily Beast he
has he took some some pictures he went
to the queue and on really took some
pictures up here's here's one of his
pictures showing this this rally
obviously as you can see they're very
very heavily attended and that's that
again is the queuing on rally now if
you're not familiar with queuing on it
is it's it's basically the the uber
conspiracy theory all of the conspiracy
theorists got together and they said
listen our theories aren't quite
deranged enough we need something bigger
we need something dumber than anything
we've conceived before and they came up
with this mega conspiracy that brings
all the conspiracies together and as I
understand it the theory is and it's all
very convoluted and as conspiracy
theories tend to be and everyone sort of
has their own slight variation and twist
on it but as I understand it and all the
people that showed up in DC this is what
they believe that there exists this
massive but secretive cabal of Satanists
who are running the world and they're
pulling the strings you know behind the
scenes on everything that happens these
the small group of people they just
determine everything with their godlike
powers but there's someone deep on the
inside someone someone I guess at the at
the White House or maybe at the Pentagon
I don't know someone named Q code name Q
and he's sending messages through
internet message boards letting
everybody know about the efforts by
Trump and by a guest q is Trump supposed
to beat Q I don't know probably not
right I don't know but anyway Trump is
is is working behind the scenes to
destroy this cabal of Satanist and and
is telling everybody about it on the
message boards and so Q is the the kind
of savior figure along with Trump and he
tells us all these stories on the
message boards and some and some people
believe it now of course in reality if
anyone cares about reality anymore Q is
just an internet troll who made up a
story and posted it online provided no
evidence provided absolutely no reason
for anyone to believe it he just said it
on a message board and and a bunch of
people read it and said yeah I'll
believe that sure why not it's it's no
it really is no different from if I were
to if I were to make an anonymous fake
Twitter account and then claim that I'm
that I have access to a secret
government time machine and I am
traveling through time and and tweeting
back and telling everyone what I see I
sent out a tweet like hey guys hanging
out with Christopher Columbus everyone
smells bad which side note I've always
thought that it'd be cool to be in a
time machine but what I always do when I
think about time machines the first
thing I think is how bad everyone must
have smelled up until about maybe 1950
and so then I think I actually wouldn't
to travel back at them anyway and then
imagine I were to do that and then
people were to see those tweets and a
few people were to say wow well this
must be true
because it's how someone said it
therefore it's true how else could
someone say something if it isn't true
it does listen I'm not trying to to join
the dog pile on these maniacs but it
does bring to mind a question we've
talked about before but that I find
endlessly fascinating a psychological
question of why people go for this stuff
it's it's it is a certainly a a minority
of people and you can tell from that
picture there it's a rather small matter
but but it's also it it also is a bigger
group of people then you would like to
believe like with the the flatter the
flatter thing I talked about the Flat
Earth theory a while
along the show and I discovered that
yeah of course the vast majority of
people believe that the earth is round
but there is still a sizable minority of
people who actually believe that the
earth is flat and that there's a
conspiracy among NASA and all these
government agencies to to delude us to
the fact and so it that's the question
is why you do people how do people
believe this why and the answer I think
is that is that we as human beings are
amazingly adept at convincing ourselves
to believe things that we want to be
true and it's it's hard to understand
how that's even possible even though to
some extent we've all done it and we all
do it and that's why we have to work so
hard to be critical thinkers and that's
why we have to constantly be stopping
and reassessing our own beliefs even our
deepest held beliefs if to constantly
sort of turn the mirror back on
ourselves and and look and inspect and
evaluate those beliefs because we know
that it is so easy for people to believe
things that are crazy and and to
convince themselves of things just
because they want those things to be
true we know that and so it's easy for
us to say well yeah obviously people do
that a lot of people do it everyone but
not me I don't do that this is everybody
that's and everyone else problem not a
me problem but we know everyone does it
and so I think that's why we have to
even if we're not queuing on people we
probably have a few beliefs that if we
were to just stop and reevaluate them we
would realize wow there is no reason for
me to believe this I just do and and so
that's why we have to do that now for me
there's I feel like from now I know that
I have this problem too because that we
all have we all have this problem I also
I guess because I'm neurotic I also have
an opposite problem so I have both my
opposite problem is I'm also very good
at convincing myself that things
I don't want to be true are true so I'm
very good at this is where hypochondria
kicks in where I could I mean I could
you you tell me about a disease any
disease and I couldn't convince myself
in five minutes that I have it I can
really convince myself that I have that
disease and really believe it even as I
realize that what I'm doing that this is
there's no I'm just I'm inventing this
it's all psychosomatic I can still
convince myself of it I don't know why I
do that but I do because I'm I'm also
insane the human mind is a very very
strange very strange place we'll go to
emails Matt Walsh show at gmail.com Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com this is from
Theresa says dear Matt I am a 22 year
old woman from Vienna Austria and I
listened to your show almost every day
in a recent show you were talking about
rights and the fact that the word is
being used too much for things that are
luxuries and conveniences rather than
rights well I am a Catholic myself and
believe in God given rights I find it
hard to argue for the existence of the
objective rights without invoking a
religious belief rights are by your
statement something that doesn't have to
be given to the individual by an
authority like the state but then what
are rights how do we know without
arguing religiously that we even have
rights like a right to life etc does the
fact that we are alive conclude that we
should have a right to live I just
decided to play a devil's advocate on
this one thank you for your great
insightful show this is a so this is a
great example of it I didn't even plan
it this way but this is a great example
of what I just talked about this and
this is turning the mirror back around
and re-evaluating your own beliefs and
the things that you just assumed to be
true and so you should be commended for
that tree so and that's a good question
we talked about this idea of rights we
take it for granted but what actually is
it where do we get this idea that people
have a right to anything maybe no one
has a right to anything I think that
yeah I was talking recently about the
book sapiens by you've all her re and a
book that as I said I found interesting
even though I disagree with 85% of it
he argues that rights don't exist he
says that they're just a cultural myth
that we came up with because
sort of obvious reasons it makes society
work now that is from his presumably
atheist perspective and from that
perspective he's right I think without
God
the idea of rights has no real objective
meaning a right is is is then determined
culturally and politically because where
else could it come from if there is no
God if we live in a material universe
and everything is subject to the laws of
nature there's nothing beyond that then
there's then rights are just an idea
then it is really a myth it's a story
it's a narrative that we've come up with
and we tell each other and we agree to
it culturally and politically any time
we use the word rights then we use it in
the sense that I would use it if I said
something like you know I have a right
to X amount of money from my employer
what I would mean by that is this is the
amount we agreed to it's not that it's
god-given it's not that I just could
march in and say I have a right to this
money no it's it's it's that we sat down
and we agreed to X and so I have a quote
right to it because that's what we
agreed to so it's in that in that case a
right would be it seems to me an
arbitrary thing like we agreed to this
amount we could have agreed to that
amount or that amount it means this is
just the amount we agreed
so then rights would be but by the
secular perspective rights it would seem
to me are arbitrary things that we agree
to as a society that's what rights
become from a secular perspective the
deeper sense of rights
it seems to me art that's entirely
religious and see that's the problem
when people would get in this discussion
about was America founded on Christian
values and so on and so forth it's clear
that our founding fathers many of them
were not Christian Thomas Jefferson
Benjamin Franklin many of them were
deists which is to say not Christian by
any stretch of the imagination but they
did believe in in God they did believed
in some sort of creator and and it's
it's clear that
although our country wasn't founded on
Christianity in the sense that it's not
a theocratic state it was founded on a
religious notion of human rights there
is no other way to put it that's what it
says in the Declaration of Independence
it's the Declaration of Independence
explains what the founders considered
rights to be and they said rights are
things are endowed by the creator if
there's no a creator there's no one to
endow them and then rights are as I said
arbitrary things that we came up with
and I don't think there's any way around
that so I guess that that's the answer
that as if you believe in God then I
think you can talk about rights in a way
that is coherent and makes sense but you
can't really talk about it in an
entirely secular way now if if some if a
secularist or atheist out there wants to
try to meet the challenge and give me an
objective definition for rights that
does not rely on anything metaphysical I
would love to hear it
I don't think you can though all right
this is from Andy says hi Matt your your
your reminiscing of 9/11 made me realize
that you and I are the same age so my
crucial question to you is what are your
top five albums of 2003 mine are five
room on fire The Strokes for heavier
things John Mayer 3 shoots to narrow the
shins to love is hell Ryan Adams one
elephant the White Stripes second
question when you become our supreme
theocratic fascist dictator will into
club 50 cent be vilified and caused for
a swift execution wind played or will it
be allowed if it's enjoyed ironically so
I like this question is very specific
2003 I had to guide to go look up what
albums were released in 2003 and I found
out there a lot of great album maybe
that's why you choose chose the year
2003 a lot of great albums came out in
2003 here's what I would say number one
I'm gonna agree with you elephant white
stripes great great rock album - I'm
gonna go jay-z the black album three
decoration day by the drive-by truckers
because I really I like to drive-by
truckers a lot for the the Outkast album
came out there I forget the name of it I
didn't write it down and then five I'll
go with the shins shoots to narrow
now when you mention in the club as far
that's just a great classic song so I
know in fact if you if you enjoy it
ironically that's when you're going to
be in trouble because there should be no
irony that it's just a good solid song
and I will stick by that to my dying day
this is from Simon Says hi Matt I am a
former atheist and currently a Christian
I really enjoy CS Lewis's books about
Christianity scroop Screwtape Letters
problem of pain and mere christianity
are all really insightful books that i
that have strengthened my belief
atheists often talk about pain and
suffering as proof that there is no
loving and good god this argument is
easy enough to debunk and short i say
that our suffering as a result of our
abuse of free will however humans suffer
for other reasons as well the most
obvious of which are natural disasters
us Christians believe that God has
orchestrated the flow of events in the
universe which has caused the world to
be set as it is the one anomaly is the
free will of human beings natural
disasters are obviously not products of
humanity's free will
I have heard Christians argue that God
uses natural disasters to punish humans
for our sins however infants are among
the victims of these catastrophes who
are unable to sit in for the time being
I am very curious as to where you stand
on this issue and how you argue against
these atheists you've probably talked
about this in the podcast before so I
apologize for asking such a normal
question well Simon I don't I don't
think the problem of suffering is easy
enough to debunk as you say in fact I
don't think it can be debunked at all I
wouldn't use the word debunk and I
suspect that if you were to if CS Lewis
were alive today and I think problem
with pain is a great book which is a one
of the best treatments of this question
that I think has ever been produced by a
Christian in one of the things that
makes it a great treatment is that it's
simple it's easy to understand there are
a lot of Christian philosophers out
there who have dealt with this and a
problem in a more intricate denser kind
of way but those a lot of those books
can be very hard to read and understand
CS Lewis was great breaking it down
simple concepts everyone
understand anyway but I suspect that if
you were to talk to see us Lewis if you
were alive today he would say that no I
didn't do bunk the problem of suffering
though or the problem of pain wouldn't
use that word at all in the sense of I
don't think we can we can say well
see here's why they're suffering I've
proven it next question
that's over I don't think we can do that
it is a live question as it were and I
think it will it will remain a live
question forever partly for the reason
you mentioned in your email that
suffering includes lots of things that
are not directly the result of human
choices natural disasters are one of
them Dorian destroyed the Bahamas nobody
the Bahamas did anything to cause that
that's not how hurricanes work we know
how weather patterns work now and we
know where they come from
it's a meteorological phenomenon and and
and and that's it that's how they happen
and it's not just natural disasters I
saw something on Twitter yesterday a
picture of a four-year-old child that a
mother had posted for your child with
leukemia who was leaning over a toilet
vomiting and a picture that just as a
parent just absolutely gutted me by I
cannot imagine going through that I
cannot imagine my child going through
that and me as a parent having to watch
helplessly I it's unthinkable it's the
worst thing in the world I can't even it
takes my breath away just thinking about
but so did that four-year-old choose
that is that his free will that caused
cancer obviously not he is suffering
entirely apart from his own choices and
there are many other examples are
billions of examples we could list of
suffering that people go through that
they didn't cause so the free will
answer doesn't entirely solve the
problem especially when you take into
account the view of God as a sort of
ground of all being which is Paul
Tillich's phrase Tillich was a
Protestant theologian 20th century
I guess be considered liberal which i
think is maybe an oversimplification but
he his ideas with God would be his ID
many of his ideas about God in the Bible
would be rejected by most Christians
myself included but if you understand
that phrase a certain way at least this
is how I understand the idea of God as
the ground of all being which maybe is
not how Tillich understood it
God is the ground of being in the sense
that God is the source of all being God
is the necessary reality everything else
is contingent upon God God is what
another way of putting it God is what
holds all things in existence so the you
know the old children's song he's got
the whole world in his hands in a sense
I think that's true you know you know in
a metaphorical sense he's not literally
with physical hands holding up the globe
but in a sense he holds all things in
his hands nothing can exist outside of
God's will there can't be anything
existing where God goes gee I would
really like it if that didn't exist and
I would stop it from existing if I could
but I just can't my hands are tied
that that that can't be because then God
would not be all-powerful so if
something exists then it seems to me
that God must not only accept that it
exists
but must in some way maintain it must
keep it in its being because otherwise
it could not exist that is not to say
that all bad actions that people do is
really God doing them I'm not saying
that but I'm saying all things that
exists all phenomena that is you know
all natural phenomena all of that must
be held in existence by God right I
don't see any way around that this makes
the problem of suffering more profound
because then we must ask you know when a
when a person has cancer what a child
has cancer is it not the case that in a
certain sense God is holding that cancer
in existence what I mean is
God could snap his fingers
metaphorically and the cancer would go
away but he doesn't most of the time God
could have made all four year-olds
impervious to cancer now that's not and
why didn't he you know and that's not an
easy question for Christians to wave-off
I think you might I think sometimes we
wave this off and we say Fath that's
stupid
hey why would he have done that hey you
can't you can't ask these questions you
can't ask these questions and they're
good questions that don't have easy
answers because after all if you were
God that's what you would do right and
you can say well yes but you're not God
and we cannot understand the ways of God
that's true but when we call God loving
we can only understand love as in some
sense analogous to human love if it
isn't you know if God's love is not in
any sense analogous to human life then
it doesn't make any sense for us to call
him loving because then that word
doesn't really mean anything in relation
to himself so it must be if we are
supposed to understand God as being
loving that it mutt then his love must
be in some way analogous to our love
although the a perfect version of it and
so then we would say well you know if
why wouldn't God's love prevent
four-year-olds from getting cancer
because if I could I would so there are
only three ways of answering and so this
to me this is the the hardest we talked
about the problem of suffering as you
said you know the the sort of easiest
version is why do why do bat why does
God allow bad people to do bad things
okay freewill got that okay I think that
is that's as close to sort of debunking
as you can do for that part of the
question
gotta have free will if we don't have
free will then we're just robots we're
automatons what's the point of existence
in that case and if we can't choose to
do evil then how can we really choose to
do good how can we choose to love if we
can't choose that all of that great okay
the hard
element of the problem suffering is what
we're talking about right now
natural disasters children with cancer
to me that is like where a tree that's
when your rubber really meets the road
with this question and that's when all
of the try Pat simple answers just do
not work so but it seems to me that
there there there are three ways of
answering this riddle about for instance
just using this example of children with
cancer okay one there are three possible
answers that a person could get one God
is not really loving to God does not
exist
three God is loving and does exist and
childhood cancer fits into that picture
in some way that we cannot possibly
understand or conceive as Christians we
give the third answer right but the
third answer isn't really an answer
exactly it's the admission of a lack of
answer it's it's the faith that someone
other than ourselves
has the answer namely God and that's the
best we can do I think there is no
debunking here I think there is only a
humble acceptance of our own ignorance
and a faith that some deeper truth some
as yet unseen clarity exists outside of
our realm of understanding I you know
I've thought a lot about this problem as
I think you have a lot of people have
it's not a lot about it I've read a lot
about it and my conclusion is that
that's the best we can do is there must
be an answer I don't know it and that's
the problem of suffering as I see it but
you know we it's it's something we get
you know that also means that we don't
just I don't think we ever get to a
point where we can just put it on the
shelf and say I forget about that I
think we can you continue to think about
it and meditate on it and you know pray
about it and think about it and study it
and maybe you'll come to a better
conclusion than the one that I've
arrived at which as I said is not really
the conclusion at all alright we will
leave it on that rather
morbid note and I'll talk to you
tomorrow
Godspeed the Matt Walsh show is produced
by Robert Sterling associate producer
alexia Garcia Del Rio executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clavin